hello everybody markiplier here and I've
got a special surprise for you well it's
not really a surprise because it's right
up there in the title but anyway we just
hit 5,000 subscribers on YouTube and I
was so excited I was like doing triple
backflips in my room you didn't see but
I was doing it and it was like it was so
incredible I was really really excited
and I took a screenshot I went to
Facebook Olson we had a thousand likes
on Facebook and I was like oh god I got
through quadric back lip Naumann I
totally nailed the landing [ __ ] it
but wasn't too impressed about it so
anyway I just am really grateful of all
the help that you guys have done to get
me to this point it's incredible so I
wanted to do something that gives back
to you guys
and while I can't give back to each of
you individually I can do a free game
giveaway so here's veal I bought the
4-pack the pre-order four pack of
Borderlands 2 on Steam which means I
have three copies three copies of
Borderlands 2 to give away to you guys
and you don't have to do much to win the
only thing you need to do to get your
name in the Hat for the raffle is pick
one of my videos any one of my videos
and share it on Facebook Twitter
anywhere a forum revit it doesn't matter
just the easiest way to do this go down
there right there hit that share button
and click on Facebook and Twitter and
once you do take a screenshot of it on
the page wherever you shared it and sent
it to me at this email address
markiplier at gmail.com right here is
right there and set it to be there the
reason I'm doing this is just to verify
who shared who really share because this
is a raffle and I only want that people
who are legitimate to get it that's it's
more fair to you guys more fair to
everyone if we have some sort of
verification process so just take a
screenshot and send it to me here now
being is you can share as many times as
you want you can share a hundred times
and you get your name in the Hat a
hundred times
so every time I get a picture in an
email from one of you guys I'm gonna
write your name down whatever name is in
the email so include your name I'm gonna
write the name down rip it off put it in
the Hat and make sure the name is
something unique so I don't get 10,000
Matt's and 500 marks so just put your
you preferably like your steam username
or something and put it in the Hat and
then I'll mix it up two weeks later I'm
gonna mix it up a little bit Bowl for
all of you to see and I'll pick three
names out of that and I'm gonna give the
borderlands to those guys who have won
now I don't want to discourage people
from sharing more or less so here's
another kicker the person who shares the
most because it's possible share more
than others and still not get it copy
the person who shares the most it's the
added bonus of being able to do a let's
play with me in the future the person
who shares most can pick any co-op game
and do a let's play with me just tell me
I'll get in contact with you I'll ask
you what game you want to play you pick
it you come to me
we'll play it and we'll put it on my
scale and here's one more thing the
people who win the Borderlands 2 copies
all three of them get to do it let's
play with me at a later date whenever it
comes out and whenever are doing the
whenever I'm actually gonna play it all
three of you get to do a let's play with
me and you don't even need a mic or
anything you don't have to talk it's
it's really ok if you don't but
preferably
you would have a microphone we could all
talk together but I just wanted to give
a little bit more I can't I wish I could
give a copy of Borderlands 2 to everyone
on the channel but I thought copies
would kind of put me in the poorhouse
I'd have to sell my computer my camera
my body so I don't want to do that so
anyway this is just something that I
thought would give something back to you
guys because it's you guys that have
helped me get to this
and it's you guys that are gonna help me
to get into the future so it's kind of
win-win for everybody here so thank you
all so much for everything that you've
done and just in case you missed it I'm
gonna summarize everything all one more
time again I've got three copies of
Borderlands 2 if you want to win economy
share one of my videos take a picture of
you sharing it send it to this email
address right here mark Blaire gmail.com
go to any other place ready Facebook
anywhere or Twitter some forums share
there's many times you lucky your name
in the bowl put your steam name in the
email so then I know who you are and I
put it in the bowl and I can pick out
your name and not go hey Matt
oh it's about again Oh Matt won three
copies so I can't do that so keep going
and you're gonna be great and you're
gonna do it and whoever these shares the
most it's gonna do a let's play with me
and whoever gets Borderlands ooh he's
gonna null to do a let's play with me
okay that about summarizes everything so
I'm pretty sure that's it so thank you
guys so much for everything that you've
done and in two weeks in one week I'll
do an update video to tell you guys
where we're at and how we're doing and I
might even show you the progress I made
on the big bullet aims and show that I
have to get a bigger bowl of names I
don't know how many people are gonna
share or anything like that so thank you
guys for everything you done this really
been an incredible ride to get up here
and I can I can actually see where we're
gonna go I can see what we're gonna do
it's it's it's incredible to think that
I could someday do this as a living this
huh
thank you guys so much for everything
that you've done and as always I will
see you in the next video bye bye